[Musik]
ford ist schon schwierig folgende sache
ist es gerade lvl ich habe eine
autogrammstunde um 12 uhr also 49
minuten ich muss noch zähne putzen
duschen haare für in essen dahin feiern
berufe die geht sie ja schon wie du
schon auf dem weg schon taxi gestellt
mich sehr
ja klar erst danach schaute hatte ich
halt irgendwie so sechs sieben
interviews oder so
der rat oder wurde ich gefragt hey was
heißt eigentlich so viel machen und ilja
streiks folgen erst gebaut sondern über
arbeit mit kurzes update ihres tattoos
ist man viel zu stehen
ich sitze jetzt nicht im taxi aber mein
vater mich grad hin weil ich habe jetzt
nicht mehr so zeiten noch ein taxi
bekommen wir die alle leider bei der
gamescom sind aber auf jeden fall
beginnt eine autogrammstunde genau um 11
uhr also in fünf minuten dann mal
schauen ob ich das schaffe ich an der
stelle hätte schauder dann die videotext
letzten 400 metern mussten auf den
verband werden
fussball bitte sowie überlegen ist nur
ganz locker machen paar interviews
sicherlich will jemand sein instagram
postulat laser ok alles klar
zu kurz
mein name ist was faul man die
helligkeit
es ist nicht meine autogramm schon jetzt
von der form darüber verlegt nach hier
freuen und entstehen dahin irgendwie
noch menschen einstehen die alonso mache
ich jetzt noch fällig und das ist alles
ja schon fast ins rutschen lassen etwas
die ganze zeit forschen wirklich nicht
nein wirklich nicht was echt voll lieb
gerade ganz okay laser luca ok ansonsten
findet ihr den link auf ihrer ersten
seite der infobox
da hinten sitzt ein spaß haben erkennen
kann aber erst mal an
karsten speck wird von dienstag an
pushen
autogramm schon der ist zu ende wir
haben tatsächlich nur 7 40 minuten
überzogen das ist ein neuer
negativrekord ich könnt ihr euch noch an
das essen gestern in der youtube ändern
einfach nur literatur klar schaue mir
das essen hier aus
da schmeckt genauso beschissen sondern
nach dem essen habe ich jetzt endlich
ein bisschen bauchschmerzen liegen
gerade die ganzen geschenke die ich
bekommen habe jetzt schon mal danke
die ganzen stofftiere glaube wenn ich
irgendwann kinder haben sollte brauche
ich nicht stofftiere für die k so viele
gut also oktober geplanten tour sagen
kann nächsten wochen soll nur für schöne
[Applaus]
man vielleicht gerade krankheit flammen
wollte ein foto mit mir machen
doch und weil das essen geschmeckt hat
habe ich mir gedacht ich haben uns
weiten teilen
sag mal bist du für dein autogrammstunde
[Musik]
jetzt sind sie wieder bei aufnahmen die
am 8
ja ist ein schnäppchen sagt da sagt das
wahlrecht luca alles klein geschrieben
und zusammen luca interessant da heißt
ich laser luca das habt ihr gut gemacht
alle sehen heute gut aus sogar luca
sieht gut aus und was kommt dann
berlinicke luca ausraster wo bist du ihr
wart gestaltungsraum ist damit die sache
aber so folgt das werde ich auch besser
zweite autogrammstunde auch beendet wir
haben diesmal tatsächlich nur 39 minuten
überzogen habe ich habe alle
durchgekriegt jedoch an gestanden sind
im nachtwerk haben andere youtuber dann
sind wir sogar extra noch zu einem
anderen stand hingegangen und haben dort
an weiter geschrieben ich habe irgendwas
auf der insel jetzt weg danke auf jeden
fall auch in die ganzen kleinen
geschenke die wiederum passend auch
schon auf dem weg zu mir nach hause ich
wäre jetzt auf jeden fall abgeholt und
dann fahre ich selber auch nach hause
ist jetzt mal wieder nicht mittags die
sonne mein vater war so lieb mich
abgeholt
jetzt hast jetzt heute erstmal nur unten
ok effekt hier ist wahrscheinlich gerade
schon gesehen hat bin ich jetzt wieder
zu hause angekommen und als ich
angekommen bin war
wer klingelt jetzt auf jeden fall beim
eine reinigungskraft halt gerade da ist
jutta eckert die direkt auf jeden fall
war die einfach ihr mir älter man dann
hier voll lustig die will
konstellationen allen parteien ich habe
es auf jeden fall gerade den blog geld
fertiggestellten in ihrem vorgestern
gesehen hat und jetzt gerade kommt schon
andere freundin von mir erwartet sie
kommen jeden moment an jeden moment
kommen sie an
durch die tür in dem moment da halo auf
jeden fall jetzt duschen dass er zum 1
ich mache mich so klar da habe ich
einfach jeden die anlagen einfach
spannender verzichtet man dazu sagen so
folgt das war ein echtes fantreffen hat
echt spaß gemacht und das ist tobias und
die härte caroline bono wir heißen ein
instagram account du hast deine eigenen
instagram account bruder schön dass ich
heute bei und sie haben alles so wie du
stinkst es hässlich halle luca dürfte
noch mehr als noch hässlicher 60
bekommen zudem wird in dem jungen nie
ist dass man immer schön wie ist das
denn aussehen wie ein kanarienvogel wir
gehen jetzt zur instagram video dvd und
danach zur busabfahrt ich habe aber ich
nehme auf jeden fall mein handy wird
also die kamera bleibt hier das heißt
die nächsten aufnahmen und jetzt wird
ihr handy
august
seine pässe
[Musik]
mir ist gestern tatsächlich etwas
passiert was mir so meiner kompletten
bisher so noch nicht passiert ist wir
waren halt auf dieser instagram party
und irgendwie wasser halt total kacke
und ich wollte eigentlich erst über nach
hause fahren und dann waren wir aber
nachher noch im bootshaus das irgendwie
vier uhren dann machen wir halt nach
sollte die anwendung gerade gesehen auf
jeden fall war mir dann halt irgendwann
wieder zu hause und habe einfach
vergessen
im outro für den ersten tag des flug
stopps zu machen und dann habe ich
außerdem vergessen zu locken wie ich
gerade aufgestanden bin und so weiter
und so fort
also ich bin schon den besten fahrern
der welt das tut mir auf jeden fall
leider ist es heute aussieht als wäre
einfach nichts passiert zwischen gestern
party und jetzt gerade ist es ja auch
nicht aber normalerweise blog ich halt
immer und sage dass ich jetzt schlafen
gehen dass der nächste tag kommt und
zweitens war aber es hat einfach
vergessen aber dafür ist er ja wieder
einmal im block drin was schaut er sich
an mann und mein blog
[Applaus]
[Musik]
eröffnen mit meinen freunden ich
versuch's gestern auf einer party waren
wir da so nett bis das sitzen auf den
dienstag
laser luca ok folgende sache ich sitze
gerade so mein handy lädt halt hier mit
dem ladekabel was da an der steckdose
zum klar wie viel prozent das die sache
prozent und sie so ich will auch laden
die schnell da liegt auch eine liga
sowieso ist aber nicht eingeschritten
die volksvertreter den richtigen plan
vor die werke auf jeden fall erstmal ja
zum flughafen bringen war der geistig
nach berlin und ich glaube dass wir dann
keine ahnung was wir machen werden habe
ich ja gesagt dass wir nicht genau
wissen was geht wahrscheinlich fahren
wir auch new voices festival ganz
spontan erst gar nicht abbringen
ja ich bin jetzt der staat habe ja ich
habe keinen bart
[Musik]
schüssel ja alles klar grösster bringen
da möchte man instagram pushen für den
blog jetzt gerade bereits gesehen habe
habe ich sabrina und jetzt am flughafen
hier darf der flug habe ich habe mich
als abgesetzt die werden jetzt zurück
nach berlin fliegen das heißt wir sehen
uns jetzt ja bei mir wenn ich wieder bei
carola tomizawa alleine meiner wohnung
[Musik]
das übrigens schiri nicht auch noch mit
wegen der sind wir jetzt losgefahren
wenn du dich entscheiden müssen zwischen
carola und den bären zu nehmen dem werde
[Applaus]
ich bin schön schaut man da hinten
müssen pinkeln das heißt man regen
geräusch wir sind jetzt im westen
angekommen das heißt die nächsten
aufnahmen werden mit dem drei punkte ein
weil ich meine kamera nicht mitnehmen
[Musik]
wir sind also das ist denn im kapitel
jetzt macht das licht aus
[Musik]
wir sind wieder zurück in köln
angekommen hier vielleicht wissen wir zu
viert oder zu zweit das liegt einfach
daran weil carola und wir ihn irgendwie
da irgendwelche leute kennengelernt
haben und es ist gerade voll dunkel in
der kamera auf jeden fall will sie zwei
zurückgefahren und laufen jetzt zu
bewahren ist gerade noch mal dünner
essen und irgendwie komplett tod
vollkommen wieder toni geht ihr gut
auf jeden fall spielen wir ziehen und
runde tiefer weil wir uns irgendwie die
zeit totschlagen wollen weil gleich
jetzt konnte man dagegen besser
bekämpfen die um 5 uhr und das ist halt
leider erst in einer stunde 20 1 60 bis
1 macht bleiben alter
was geht auch freunde hier ist er wieder
der beste blocker der welt ihr könnt
euch bestimmt auch die szene gerade
erinnern wo ich gesagt habe akon
wirtschaften safe nicht bis zu dem kampf
noch wach zu bleiben
ja haben wir auch nicht geschafft wir
sind hier eingeschlossen
hi dementsprechend habe ich auch kein
auto gestern abend mehr gemacht einfach
wie gesagt eingeschlafen sind und jetzt
aufgewacht und ich darf doch gegen den
kampf verpasst und ich habe kein auto
mehr gemacht
ich bin der beschissenen steve locher
der welt trotzdem ist dieser blog jetzt
hier zu ende wenn euch gefallen hat
würde ich mich selber live freuen war
eine ganz spontane aktion dass wir noch
zu dem festival gefahren sind und sie
noch kein abonnent von meinem kanal seid
könnt ihr einfach unter dem video auf
den abonnieren knopf drücken und dann
verpasst du keine videos mehr und wenn
ihr schon abonnent zeit könnt ihr auf
die glocke klicken
denn dann bekommt die benachrichtigung
wenn ich etwas neues hoch laden und
mache ich ja immer so dass ich am ende
eines videos die kamera vor die tür
stellen so von wegen ich zeige euch ich
aufstehe und ich zeige euch nicht wenn
die tür zumachen von wegen er jetzt das
dunkel ist das vorbei wird jetzt leider
keinen sinn machen weil es hell draußen
ist deswegen jetzt einfach ja
[Musik]